[Music]
[Applause]
dog control
reports ready sir hell ready sir
obviously departure plot sir yard
command signaling clear sir
maneuvering thrusters new bring
thrusters old station
station keeping sir
[Music]
[Applause]
wax on wax off macdonald
wax on hat wax off that
concentrate look at my eye rocker hand
thumb inside maxon hat
me penta fence up done
up down
up done other side
look i always look eye
[Applause]
hold it huh you guys are under arrest
[Music]
what are you night security well no
actually i'm a
pizza delivery
stay down
did i mention i studied martial arts
[Applause]
i've known all of you for so long
rose lina waverly
since we were babies and kids fighting
over dolls
it's amazing isn't it
[Music]
auntie lindo auntie yinging
auntie on me long time friends of my
mother
you are like second mothers to me
in so many ways truly
[Music]
i mean you gave her back to me by
finding my sisters
you've given me something i can still do
for her
here i thought it was too late well it
isn't
[Music]
[Applause]
the price you pay for bringing up either
my chinese or american heritage as a
negative
is i collect
just like this here
now if any of you sons of got anything
else to say
now
i didn't think so
[Music]
[Applause]
dance with me
[Music]
will vivian shane
i am asking you to dance with me
[Music]
i can't
there's no music
[Applause]
this is either a really smart move or by
far the stupidest thing that we've ever
tried
well we're about to find out
mush i told you this was
[Music]
am i really high is this actually
working
oh this is awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i forgot um i've decided i won't let
you kick me out of the family
since i'm a member of the family who
would stand to reason that i would get a
vote and whether or not i get kicked out
and that vote would have to be unanimous
standard parliamentary procedures so
all those in favor of not kicking kumail
out of the family raise your hand
great motion to kick kamal out of the
family denied
so you guys can just talk to me
okay you're giving me the silent
treatment
i figured that was what was gonna happen
i have a solution
so hi how are you that's just a real
basic one
you know past the salt
practical always with the comedy
mom made that one specially for you
kamel how did you become so much more
handsome than your brother
naveed [ __ ]
i admit this one is designed to stir up
some controversy
it's interesting how you can't really
kick someone out of your family because
they
will always be your family
i agree with that
[Applause]
there is a hopkin phrase kagilang
it means our own kind of people
and you're not our own kind because i'm
not rich
because i didn't go to a british
boarding school or i wasn't born
into a wealthy family you're foreign
american and all americans think about
is their own happiness
don't you want nick to be happy it's an
illusion
we understand how to build things that
last
something you know nothing about
you don't know me i know you're not what
nick needs
well he proposed to me yesterday
he said he'd walk away from his family
and from you for good
don't worry i turned him down
only a fool falls for winning hand
there's no winning
you made sure of that
because if nick chose me he would lose
his family
and if he chose his family he might
spend the rest of his life
resenting you
[Music]
[Applause]
so you chose for him
i'm not leaving cause i'm scared or
because i think i'm not enough
because maybe for the first time in my
life
i know i am
i just love nick so much
i don't want him to lose his mom again
so i just wanted you to know that
one day when he marries another lucky
girl who is enough
for you and you're playing with your
grandkids while the town halls are
blooming
and the birds are chirping
that it was because of me
a poor raised by a single mother
low-class immigrant
[Music]
nobody
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
we do it
light them up
how long before the guns get back online
i have no idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
foreign
no
foreign
okay sir how do you say congratulations
dad goshi gong see ha ha
thank you
[Music]
you all get the best of me
you ain't seen the last of me
i may go but i'll come back around
[Music]
you can give me your best shot
give it everything you got
i'm here to tell
[Music]
[Music]
i'm here to tell you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
is
i'm not pretty i'm good looking
[Music]
why
[Music]